اذا في تركيا لا حديث اليوم سوى العمل على
اعاده العلاقات مع مصر هذه الصوره او
مصافحه المونديال التي هي التي اعادت
القاهره وانقره الى طاوله المفاوضات وان
كانت على المستوى الدبلوماسي
والاستخباراتى مبدايا مبدا من الرئيس رجب
اردوغان ووزراء حكومته يتحدث المسؤولون
الاتراك بايجابيه عن ضروره اعاده وتصحيح
مسار العلاقات مع مصر وزير الخارجيه
التركي مولود اوغلو تحدث اليوم
لامكانيه اعاده السفراء بين البلدين خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله وما بين هذه
الاشهر ستجر مباحثات طويله وشائكه وشاقه
لمناقشه قضايا عالقه بين البلدين لاسيما
ملف دعم اردوغان للاخوان كيف لا وهو الذي
طال ما رفع اصابعه الاربعه نقي اشاره الى
اشاره الاخوان المحظوره هذا الملف
بالاضافه الى ملف مرتزقه تركيا الموجودين
في ليبيا قد يستخدمها اردوغان للضغط
لتلبيه مطالبه التي اقتصرت على شرط واحد
فقط وهو تعديل مصر لموقفها من تنقيب تركيا
عن الغاز في البحر المتوسط خصوصا وان مصر
لديها تحالف قوي مع كل من اليونان وقبره
بدوره هنا الرئيس اردوغان فؤاد اقطاي كشف
عن سبب تغيير الموقف التركي قائلا ان
التحولات الجيوسيا الاخيره في الشرق
الاوسط انعكست على مقاربه الدول المنطقه
ايضا
[موسيقى]